[Music]
the router is one of the most powerful
yet underutilized tools and angular in
addition to defining the URL structure
for your app it can also be used to
control performance with lazy loading
and help you write dry code with
resolvers and guards over the next few
minutes you'll learn the basics of the
angular 6 router plus a few advanced
techniques to preload data from firebase
and protect routes from unauthenticated
users if you're new here like and
subscribe and grab the full write-up
from angular firebase com the first
thing we'll do to get started is
generate a brand new angular 6 app with
the router flag that'll just give us a
routing module automatically the first
thing we'll want to look at is the
router outlet when you route to a
component it needs to be the child of
some other component which by default
will be the app component and the root
of the project so the outlet tells
angular where to render a component
based on the URL that the user navigates
to we can define our routes by going
into the app routing module and you'll
see we have an array that's typed to the
routes interface we can define each
route in our application as an object
which will take a couple of
configuration parameters the most basic
use case would be to give your route up
path and then route it to a specific
component that you've generated let's
run ng generate component and we'll call
this the home page now the home page we
could set up as the root path so we'll
give that a path property of an empty
string then set the component option to
the home component if we serve the app
we should see the home component
rendered at the position of that router
outlet then notice how other content in
the home component is still there such
as the logo and header that'd be a good
place to put a nav bar at a footer and
things that'll be present on every page
that's a good start but let's look at
how we can navigate between multiple
components by generating another one
called animals then we can import the
component into our router module and set
up another path and component property
for this route when setting up
hyperlinks in angular you don't use a
normal H rep attribute like you would in
a plain HTML page if you use a regular
href that'll cause your angular app to
completely reload whenever it's clicked
instead we use the router link directive
which tells angular to
treat this as an internal route then we
simply pass it the path that we would
normally route to you with a link so now
if we open up the app in the browser we
can click on this animals link and it
will route us to the corresponding
component so that takes care of your
most basic use case but what happens in
the real world
is generally you're pulling some
information from a database then route
to a specific ID to show more
information about that item and you
might have thousands or millions of
items in your database so you can't just
hard code all of those routes manually
in this next section we'll create a
component called animal detail and we're
going to make it a child route of
animals you can create child routes that
will be rendered inside of their parent
by adding the children property to the
parent route the children property
itself will take an array of routes so
we just have a classic tree structure
here we can define a dynamic URL
parameter by putting a colon in front of
whatever that parameter is in this case
we're going to be looking up animals by
their name in our database so we'll set
up colon name as that URL parameter
doing this means that we can navigate to
routes that will look like animal slash
elephant animal slash hard work or any
other dynamic property that we pass to
the second half of that URL segment
you'll notice that we're dynamically
generating a list of links that we're
pulling from firebase so let me show you
how I do that
in the parent component I have an array
of documents that I pulled from fire
store so I can loop over them
asynchronously with ng4 and the async
pipe then to build a link instead of
passing it a string
I'll put brackets around the router
links so we can pass it an expression
which in this case will be an array
where each item in that array represents
a URL segment so the first half of the
segment is animals and the second half
will be the animals name because this is
a parent component we'll need to tell
the router where to render that child
components which we can do with a router
outlet the actual data in the database
is just a collection of animals that
have a few properties on each document
inside the parent component we can
retrieve these documents with pretty
much just a single line of code we
inject firestore in the constructor and
then reference these documents as the
animals property and call value changes
to listen to them as a real-time
observable and the child the component
things are a little more tricky because
we need to also listen to
the change in the URL parameter to get
the proper animal from the database the
angular router provides a service called
activated route that allows us to listen
to state changes in the router and then
we'll also import the switch map
operator from rxjs the important thing
to understand here is that the component
is only initialized once when the first
route is navigated to any child routes
that are navigated to after that won't
be called with ng on a net so what we
want to do here is use activated route
to listen to changes in that URL
parameter which is the animals name
which we can do by calling route per a
map which returns an observable of the
route parameters then when a change
occurs we'll call switch map to switch
to an observable of the actual animal
data from buyer store notice how we're
calling params get name which matches
the dynamic URL segment that we said and
the router config so that returns the
actual name of the animal which we can
then pass on to fire store to retrieve
as a single document the last step is
just to unwrap this document in the
child component so we can do that with
ng if animal async then set that as a
template variable of animal and we'll
just show some of the properties here in
the components such as the name bio and
image and you know have a structured
router tree that will scale up to as
many documents as you have saved in the
database up until this point we've only
been using router links to navigate but
you can also navigate directly from
inside of the components type script
there are many cases where you just
can't use a link click to navigate to a
page and you want to do it in a more
dynamic way maybe you have some really
ugly animals in your database and you
want to prompt the user to say yes
before navigating in this case we will
import the router directly into our
component will set up a click handler
here that will first prompt the user to
confirm that they want to navigate to
this page and then if they type in yes
we'll go ahead and navigate to that page
manually with the router you can say
router navigate and have it go to the
array of URL segments that you point it
to back in the HTML we can go ahead and
remove the router link and replace it
with the click event that will run our
click handler whenever it's clicked so
the key takeaway here is that you can
navigate anywhere in your angular code
outside of the scope of a regular
hyperlink now I want to go ahead and
switch gears and show you a couple
things that are just super useful to do
with the router let's say you want to
create a catch-all route that will serve
more or less as a 404 page if the user
routes to a component that doesn't exist
we can generate a new component to show
the content and then we'll say path star
star as a wild-card and you want to make
sure that this route is the very last
route in your treaty then if we go and
type in some random URL into the browser
it's going to pull up our error
component instead of just throwing a
regular error to the end user then
another very common thing you might want
to do is instead of routing to a
component you might just want to
redirect to a different route so let's
say we have a common misspelling for
animals we can just redirect to the main
animal's route when you set up a
redirect route you'll have to also add
in the path match option otherwise
angular will throw an error if we go and
navigate to this route in the browser
you'll see it redirects us to the
animals component instead of bringing up
the error component that we just created
another cool thing you can do is use the
router link active directive to provide
a CSS class whenever a certain route is
active this makes it really easy to
build out UI features that show the user
which link they're currently on it
expects a list of CSS classes on the
right-hand side so we'll define an
active CSS class that will make the font
bold and a different color now you can
see we get a clear UI change every time
we go to a different link for the next
few minutes I want to move a little
beyond the basics and talk about guards
to protect routes create reusable code
and preload data into your components a
guard is just an angular service that
has some special interfaces that we can
implement to do things with the router
one of the most common use cases is to
protect routes from unauthorized users
let's go ahead and run ng generate guard
admin that will protect our routes from
any non admin users the special
interface we'll be using here is can
activate which will only activate this
route if that guard results to true
let's go ahead and lock down our animals
route by adding the can activate
property with the admin guard if we go
into the guard itself you'll see it it
is decorated with injectable just like
any other angular service the only
special thing is that has this can
activate interface that gives us some
information about the state at the route
in order for the guard to work we just
need to return a boolean which can be a
primitive work
being observable or promised it's an
observable it's going to automatically
subscribe for you so we'll go ahead and
send an alert that says only admins
allowed and then we'll return false to
block access to this route if we try to
navigate to the animals page you can see
we get this alert and the component is
never rendered but more often than not
you'll need to do this a synchronously
by checking with some API if this user
has authorization we can simulate this
by setting up a timer of 1000
milliseconds then we'll need to map the
emitted value down to a boolean then we
can also use the tap operator to show an
alert or this is a good place to
navigate to a login page or something
along those lines if we try to navigate
to the page at this time you'll see we
get a one-second delay and then it
finally blocks the route after this
observable is resolved
can activate is a very powerful
interface at your disposal but there's
also another one called resolve that can
preload data into your route do you
remember earlier how in the animal
detail component we listen to the name
parameter and then switch map to a
different observable well maybe there's
a better way we can do this imagine we
wanted to preload this data on multiple
different components we would have to
write this code for each one of them
instead of repeating ourselves let's
generate a guard called preload instead
of using they can activate interface
will use the resolve interface and you
could strong type this as well but for
now we'll just use any then we'll change
the method name to resolve and it's
pretty similar to can't activate but
instead will return the actual data that
we want to be available when this route
is navigated to and commonly that's
going to be an observable form because
you're probably pulling this data from
some external API in our case we'll do
it with angular firestorm so we can
inject that in the constructor then the
guard will have the actual parameter
name available as a plain object which
we can retrieve with next parameter in
the data as an observable but we have to
pipe in the first operator because
firebase returns real time stream and we
need this observable to complete in
order for it to work properly
now we can just comment out all of our
previous code and instead we'll just
define the animal as the data that is
now available on this route when it's
navigated to it's now available on the
route data property and then we can
apply it to this route by going back to
our router config then add the result
property to our preload guard if we open
up the app it's going to work in exactly
the same way as it did before but now
we've isolated this code in a reusable
way that we can apply to multiple routes
as needed hopefully that gives you a
basic idea about how powerful the
angular router can be I'm gonna go ahead
and wrap things up there if this video
helped you please like and subscribe and
if you really want to master the basics
of angular consider becoming a pro
member at angular firebase comm you'll
get access to a whole bunch of exclusive
content designed to help you build and
ship your app faster thanks for watching
and I'll talk to you soon